the first thing that I want to get off
the
off the plate here is more news about
the Super Jam two straight weeks of
Super Jam news and I think the one that
got us all the eye popper was
Hanson on the farm kids
40 year old men singing umbap I can't
wait yep
yep seriously what was your thought when
you saw that
I loved everything about it I know me
too me too my uh my 33 year old son was
a huge Hanson fan and I'm sure he loves
you saying that out loud yeah it will no
it won't embarrass him and and here's
why it doesn't embarrass me uh I I love
a good pop song Just because it gets
overplayed on the radio has never been
too much of a turn off for me but uh hey
one of the great popular songs one of
the great shows Carly Rae Jepsen I
secretly wanted Carly Rae on the farm
I mean you know I grew up with the
monkeys that's there's no better pop
artists than the monkeys and uh that's
all it was so
I yeah I think 80 000 people on the Farm
singing umbap is gonna be well they're
not gonna be 80 000 people at Super
Champ I may overstate just a taxi we'll
see
but you've also got Victor Wooten uh who
is amazing there's not a better bass
player on the planet right now
um
wolf pack and our man Devin uh yeah it
yeah we said last week that uh while I
don't know a lot about Corey doing a lot
Corey Wong doing some of the
research the guy knows what he's doing
he knows how to put together this kind
of a an act so I imagine we will be
there yeah I'm excited about the uh sort
of mini reunion of the wolf pack
um because the one thing about that band
that is so surprising is that if you
ever like watch videos of them none of
them look like they sound you know that
old thing that we said about Saint Paul
and you know he so he looks like my
accountant uh and you would never have
put the the look of him to the sound of
him Wolfpack is the exact same way
um that yeah I mean I was actually
pleasantly surprised whereas originally
when I was like oh Corey Wong
interesting the actual group that they
put together is uh is quite fun uh I
wonder if like not only do they do
MMMBop but they do something completely
off the reservation you know and all of
a sudden they go into it's like a
Leonard Skynyrd tracker yeah
bizarre that only would make sense for
like
not make sense but only would be funny
if Hansen did it
I'm betting we don't get a full you know
three or four minutes of unbop it might
be oh come on don't do that to me it'd
be funny to leave if you only do 90
seconds
that would be funny though to start that
and then go into free bird or something
yeah that you wouldn't expect from that
that's another Little Dicky moment
well no that's not what I meant at all
that was terrible he started to play the
song and then just you know stop and
then just set it it what he said it's an
eight minute video guys what do you
expect yeah it was terrible that's not
what I mean exactly that's what I came
here one song anyone wanted to hear
exactly exactly
no no guys they're here to get to see me
get naked okay now they're really here
to see my my hair for my hype man my
hype man do 20 minutes that's what they
came for I mean honestly what a great
name for a band hype man
yeah I no I love it I'm really uh I have
always said that the the things that I
love about Bonnaroo are these bizarre
bookings that sound ridiculous uh on
paper Hansen's one of them you know
Kenny Rogers back in the day I still
think that we'll work on the farm is
Hootie the Blowfish I mean what a I want
these kind of corn corn and how much how
exciting it is to just think about the
idea of corn uh being there we all uh
you know saw the Limp Biscuit thing you
know last year uh did you ever think
you'd see corn and Hanson at the same
Festival yeah right I know
I I think I think it is really really
unique and I'm uh I'm all in on it I
want more eye poppingly goofy bookings
like that uh I'm just trying to figure
out what Devin and Victor Wooten could
do together I mean dude Devin can do
everything I mean I soak and Victor I I
mean that's what I mean I hope they
allow
that some some sort of partnership to
happen with that look I'm putting I'm
putting every dollar I have on on Devin
doing what's going on because he does it
at every show I mean he did that entire
Marvin Gaye album so uh yeah Devin can
run the Gambit of anything that you
throw at him
um when you get to you know we get to
the Brad picks uh Devin gavilion is
going to be top of my list uh because
that show was so good at the Mercury
Lounge a couple weeks ago I got to see
Victor at a luncheon it was a he was a
special guest he was here to perform as
a fundraiser and they did a luncheon and
he did about a 10 minute thing maybe 15
and he did uh Amazing Grace on the base
and it was incredible just incredible
so that alone is worth
plus Hanson plus Devon yeah I think it's
a it's an interesting Super Jam
yeah I'm I'm uh I'm actually quite
excited about it do you think it is
better at this point in the
the whole uh calendar do you think it's
better than what you saw with Jack
Antonoff
or do you think it's on par
uh I think it's
for me it's better yeah why is that the
what was who was the host it was um John
Hall right
the one that yeah we always come back to
that yeah that was the high water one
for me yeah uh you know again Larry
Graham and Victor Wooten are certainly
equals as far as the base but
um
I I don't know the Hanson thing is such
a wild card well I mean it fits it fits
with what Jack did with Carly Rae last
year you know
um it's the same sort of Playbook I I
mean when I look at this year's Super
Jam versus last year it feels almost you
know pound for pound sort of exactly
what they tried to do last year with it
yeah like yeah and like I said the
Hanson will probably get a lot of you
know I don't know Giggles from some
people because they were a you know a
teen youth pop band but uh they were
good at it is what I'm gonna maintain
even even when my son was singing it you
know every day all day I was like that's
a that's a good pop song just leave it
at that you know it is what it is
um I uh I'm sort of low-key now I'm
thinking about I'm sort of low-key upset
that I didn't see the uh Jack Antonoff
super super Jam last year because I
forgot all about Britt Daniel being
there
but Daniel did two songs Carly Rae did
two songs Japanese breakfast to two
songs
um
you know if they fit if they follow the
same sort of formula Hansen's gonna do
two songs it's gonna be MMMBop and
something and I oh God I
I want to start rolling the dice and
start taking chances of guessing what
song that's gonna be you know
no okay
is there one no I mean I bet if I heard
it I would know it but I couldn't name
it no
that's hysterical if you you play me
some Hanson songs let me see if I know
any of these
um I do not I promise you I do not well
I know they had when they got you know
older uh early 20s I think they put out
an album that got pretty good reviews if
I remember right so
I'm sure they did but did you that's the
idea of the novelty yeah
no but not okay not because I you know
turned my nose up at it I just no me
neither but it's not something I I you
know no put on and draw a bath too
[Laughter]
they really relaxes me